FORWARD TO REVEAL EFFORTS INSIDE
THE BUREAU TO DOWNPLAY NEGATIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
HERE WITH REACTION,
SENATOR RON JOHNSON.
THAT'S A BOMBSHELL AND WE'VE GOT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS AND I'D LIKE TO
HEAL FROM THEM.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF RANK-AND-FILE ARE
GOOD PEOPLE.
WE SEE THE CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE DOJ AND
FBI, DON'T WE?
>> WE DO.
I'M NOT QUESTIONING THE
INTEGRITY OF MOST MEMBERS OF THE
FBI EMMA THAT'S WHAT
MERRICK GARLAND IS ACCUSING US
OF.
IT'S A DIVERSIONARY TACTIC ON
HIS PART.
IN AUGUST, THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS
TOLD CHUCK IN AUGUST OF 2020 THE
FBI DEVELOPED A SCHEME TO
DOWNPLAY THE DISPARAGING
INFORMATION ON HUNTER BIDEN TO
DEEP SIX IT.
THE SAME MONTH, WE RECEIVED
UNSOLICITED BRIEFINGS.
WE ASKED AT THE TIME WHO
DIRECTED THESE BRIEFINGS?
TWO YEARS LATER, WE DON'T KNOW
WHO DIRECTED THE BRIEFINGS AND
DIE MONTHS LATER, THOSE
BRIEFINGS WERE LEAKED TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TO SMEAR
ME.
THE CORRUPTION HAS RUN DEEP AND
IT'S BEEN RUNNING DEEP AND SINCE
THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
SCANDAL.
IF REMEMBER, THE EDITING OF THE
JAMES COMEY EXONERATION EMAIL
WHERE THEY CHANGED LIKE GROSSLY
NEGLIGENT TO EXTREMELY CARELESS
TO AVOID THE CRIMINAL
TERMINOLOGY.
I DON'T TRUST THE FBI, DON'T
TRUST THE UPPER ECHELONS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND AGAIN,
THE RANK-AND-FILE, THOSE
INDIVIDUALS, IF YOU WANT TO SEE
INTEGRITY RESTORED TO YOUR
AGENCIES, YOU'VE GOT TO COME
FORWARD.
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND RON JOHNSON,
MAINTAIN YOUR AN AMENITY, BUT
WE'VE GOT TO TALK TO YOU TO
RESTORE CREDIBILITY TO YOUR
AGENCIES.
>> Sean: CHRIS WRAY COULD HAVE
DONE THE FBI THE GREATEST
SERVICE, HE COULD HAVE CLEANED
UP THE MESS AND HE COULD HAVE
STOPPED THE LINE, HE COULD HAVE
STOPPED THOSE PEOPLE THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE AND HELD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SPREADING LIES
AND MISINFORMATION ABOUT TRAUMA
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
HE COULD HAVE STOPPED THE PEOPLE
THAT WENT AHEAD WITH AND PUT
FORWARD UNVERIFIABLE INFORMATION
IN A PFIZER APPLICATION TO RUIN
CARTER PAGE'S LIFE AND
DONALD TRUMP'S LIFE.
HE HASN'T DONE NOTHING I SEE THE
CLEANUP TO FBI AND DOES HE HAVE
TO GO?
>> HE'S DONE WORSE THAN THAT.
UNDER HIS WATCH, THE PFIZER
REPORT WAS ISSUED TO, THERE WERE
FOOTNOTES THAT WERE CLASSIFIED
AND REDACTED.
THEY CONTRADICTED THE BODY, THE
FBI HAD NO KNOWLEDGE THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS TAINTED BY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION, THE
FOOTNOTE SAID THE EXACT OPPOSITE
IN OCTOBER 2016.
GENERATE 2017, THE FBI KNEW THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS TAINTED.
OF MARCH OF 20 IN THE 18 FBI
BRIEF SAID THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER HAD INTEGRITY.
OF COURSE THEY ALLOWED THE
MILLER PROBE TO GO FORWARD.
IT'S CORRUPTION AND WE'VE GOT TO
GO BACK AND RE-EXAMINE WHAT WE
ALREADY KNOW AND IN LIGHT OF NEW
INFORMATION, THE SCHEME OF THE
FBI TO DOWNPLAY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH HUNTER.
A SET OF TO TRY TO DESTROY ME
QUICKLY, NOW I'M STARTING TO
THINK MAYBE THE BRIEFING WAS ALL
ABOUT TRYING TO TAKE US OFF THE
TRAIL TRYING TO SWAY US FROM
ISSUING A REPORT THAT WE ISSUED
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2020.
THE NEWS MEDIA ADMITTED IT OR
IGNORED IT.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THERE'S
EVIDENCE AND CRIMES ON HUNTER'S
LAPTOP, CHRIS WRAY HAD IT FOR
TWO YEARS.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT EQUAL
JUSTICE?
NOT MUCH TO ME, BUT SENATOR,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
IF YOUR RACE IS PIVOTAL COME